this is the one that you saved
you are as its father
a clan of two
but you have removed your helmet
then you are a Mandalorian no more
you're cult
fractured our people
where were you then
did you think your dad was the only Mandalorian
yourself
all right kid hang on
you ready for an adventure
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie they finally
officially dropped the Mandalorian season 3
trailer so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes of course I'll be doing videos for
all the episodes it's going to be starting in
early February this year so we wanted to wait that
long if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes also be doing
episode videos for Star Wars and or that's going
to be like the next Big Star Wars series to start
as you can see this trailer is basically like the
same footage or some of the same footage that we
saw before just in crisp HD quality so it's nice
to finally get the official version of this but I
will talk about the extra footage that they didn't
put in this that we have seen before remember this
is also going to connect with what's happening on
the Ahsoka series that's probably going to jump
around in the timeline a little bit there was also
an Ahsoka teaser trailer video that they released
at Star Wars celebration recently I talked about
that during my last Mandalorian season 3 trailer
video like with the footage actually revealed
who's in the trailer so I'll link that Below in
the description like I said those episodes will
Air after the Mandalorian season 3 episodes
the Mandalorian season 3 is going to Premiere
during early February next year but the brand new
footage mostly focuses on all the mandalorians
that they're going to feature during season three
all the current mandalorians that are following Bo
Katan Kryze because remember her whole thing is
becoming the leader of all mandalorians sitting
on the best scar Throne so to speak like make all
the Game of Thrones Iron Throne jokes there were
separate trailer footage of Mando walking down a
hallway that's meant to be a replica of the main
throne room on Mandalore unless they've changed
the design it's not the actual main throne room
because I think the day flow and he wants to be
pretty accurate to what they were depicted during
Star Wars Rebels and we saw the actual Throne
Room during Star Wars rebels in the Clone Wars
it was way bigger than the throne room that was
featured in the Mandalorian season 3 trailer so
I think that's why the Mando scene is happening on
a different planet and it also features a lot of
the mandalorians that are now part of Mando's old
covert following the armor there might be other
groups of mandalorians out there because they
kind of teased that they all went to ground all
across the outer rim like there are many coverts
of surviving mandalorians it's not just these two
giant factions but that's the way they make it
seem in the teaser trailer like there's a bunch
of mandalorians that follow the armor that believe
one thing in a bunch of mandalorians that follow
Bo Katan that believe something completely
different that was the whole thing they were
hyping up during the book of Boba Fett episodes
is that the armor really really hates Bo Katan so
I think we're building up to a situation where
they're gonna Force Mando to decide who he's
going to support like does he want to join his old
covert again become a Mandalorian because that's
another big thing during the teaser trailer
footage too them actually going back to the
wreckage of the Mandalore planet and the actual
Dome City of Mandalore you see it in the teaser
trailer footage it almost looks like the wreckage
of one of the death stars but it's actually the
Dome City of Mandalore that you saw during Star
Wars the Clone Wars in Star Wars Rebels like the
Dome has been destroyed it's completely exposing
the city but the footage starts with the heavy
infantrymen played by John Favreau firing his
large heavy Blaster at the sky in the middle of
a crowd of people on this sand-based town there's
a bunch of different footage from this particular
episode on the same Planet it seems like it's the
same planet where the armor has put her new Forge
inside this Cave System remember the last time
we saw the heavy infantryman he was fighting
Mando for the honor of wielding the darksaber and
he lost there are a bunch of other mandalorians
random townspeople running around behind him
as he's firing at something in the sky because
he's the heavy infantry man all of his weapons
are powerful enough to take out a small ship so
that seems like what he's firing at then there's
a completely different scene of the same group of
people same Mandalorian same heavy infantryman
firing at something else but using their jet
packs in their regular blasters but it's the same
desert landscape it's not Tatooine it's just very
similar looking landscape to Tatooine there's two
different mandalorians using their risk grappling
hooks like the ones that you've seen Mando and
Boba Fett use in the past this new scene of Mando
and grogu in his Naboo N1 Starfighter looking at
the window just passing by a rock formation Mando
and the armor are left on good terms last season
like even though she said that you have to do all
these things on the planet Mandalore or bask
in these Waters to be considered a Mandalorian
again and regain your honor it's really his
relationship with Bo Katan during the season 3
trailer footage that they tease is deteriorating
like his relationship with her is getting worse
because she really wants the dark save paper
and she has to fight him in order to get it but
it does seem like a lot of the season will be him
working with groups of mandalorians but there are
a couple new Imperial scenes new scenes of Star
Destroyers like actual Star Destroyers that people
have during the timeline of the Mandalorian which
seems like more of a grand Admiral thrawn teaser
so I think they want you to remember that really
it's the Empire that's technically the villain and
all this there's a scene of the armor presenting
someone with a new blue Mandalorian helmet is the
same blue color that Bo Katan's night owls wear
but it's not clear if it's just another random
blue colored Mandalorian helmet she's created or
if it's connected to the night owls themselves
because it doesn't have any of the trademark Night
Owl symbols on it during my other season 3 trailer
with a different footage I talk about her new
Forge area so like I said that link is below in
the description if you want to learn about that
but it's basically her just moving her Forge and
her cover to mandalorians to a different place
and Mando visits her on this new planet there's
a new scene of a brand new Imperial character in
an office the footage is so blurry that I can't
tell who it is but the way they show him makes
it seem like he's gonna be a bigger character
during season three there's a new scene of grogu
inside the Naboo N1 Starfighter in the middle of
a dogfight with shots lighting up the canopy it's
connected to the scene of Mando doing some trick
piloting against what seems like some Imperials
in an asteroid field anytime you see a dogfight
in an asteroid field you either think of Empire
Strikes Back in that dog fight or you think of
attack of the Clones in that asteroid dog fight
with Obi-Wan Kenobi but it seems like there's a
couple other scenes of grogu pushing buttons in
the ship them using an R5 Droid in place where
grogu would normally sit with him flying in and
out of these asteroids and trying to take out this
secret facility that's also on another asteroid
so it seems like it's part of some larger mission
that they're on and it does seem like they're
bringing back those funny moments of grogu just
loving to press buttons like from season 1 with
him pressing buttons when he wasn't supposed to
and when he was banging on the cockpit telling
Mando to make the Naboo N1 Starfighter go faster
like he's doing that himself this time there's a
new scene of a bunch of mandalorians wearing blue
armor using this Dropship method to enter combat
like a group of them are literally being dropped
out of a ship like a couple missiles but they
all have jet packs so they'll start flying around
the minutes they drop out of the ship this could
be connected to the scene of the armor creating
that blue Mandalorian helmet so they could belong
to her group because there are a lot of fight
scenes that take place on this desert based Planet
it looks kind of like Tatooine but probably isn't
Tatooine they probably got everyone's notes like
we're going back to Tatooine way too many times
on all these Star Wars series stop going back to
Tatooine so much the only other thing about this
group of mandalorians is that all the mandalorians
that are part of Bo Katan's group the night owls
all wear special blue armor but they all have
special markings that mark them as night owls
there's another new scene of the armor attacking
a group inside a crowded room with her bescar
Hammer the same type of fight scene that you saw
her have at the end of season one so it seems
like she's gonna get a bunch more fight scenes to
herself like she's featured much more heavily in
season three than she was in previous Seasons
even during the book of Boba Fett because we
haven't got a lot with her character during Mando
season 2. it also seems like this scene of her
attacking the group inside the room is connected
to all the other scenes of the Mandos attacking
on this particular sand based Planet like it's
part of some larger mission that they're all
pulling off there's a new scene of Mando flying
his Naboo and one Starfighter back to Navarro I've
already talked about what's happening on Navarro
in the other season 3 trailer footage in that
other video so like I said link is below in the
description for that there's a couple other funny
scenes here with grief karga he's kind of taken
over the town become the administrator since the
end of the book of Boba Fett season one there's a
new scene of Bo Katan eating food with grogu just
seeming like it's totally casual like she's not on
the outs with Mando at this point I think they're
kind of playing it both ways like there's a lot
of tension between them because she wants the dark
saber and she's trying to get the Mana to do what
she wants him to do but a lot of his Allegiance
is still with the armor who hates Bo Katan so
this is a weird triangle going on between them
there's a random scene of a bunch of Baboo Frick
aliens who are working on something in a regular
shop now it's not actual Babu frick from the rise
of Skywalker it's just a bunch of members of his
race working on something there's an unfinished CG
shot of Mando on a lush green Planet standing near
a waterfall the CG is unfinished so it looks
kind of raw but it's a completely different
planet that they've been on before there's a new
shot of a full Imperial Star Destroyer inside
Imperial shipyards we haven't actually seen
a full Star Destroyer on the series in moff
Gideon's Flagship was just a cruiser Bo Katan
stole that at the end of season two like They
confiscated it after they captured him there's
actually separate footage of her piloting that
and piloting the ship that they stole during the
Mandalorian season 2. remember she's been stealing
MAF Gideon ships just to bolster her forces in
their bid to retake the planet Mandalore so it
just sounds like we'll see scenes with her flying
around on those ships but the whole thing with
the Star Destroyer is that it seems like it's a
scene connected to the Empire and it seems like
it would be more connected to Grand Admiral thrawn
because moth Gideon as far as we know didn't have
any actual full Star Destroyers I think the idea
is that during season three like maybe at the end
there'll be some kind of tag scene that will tease
Grand Admiral thrawn or someone will mention him
again during season three because Ahsoka mentioned
his name during season two so why wouldn't we see
him but I think Grand Admiral thrawn will become
an even bigger thing we'll actually see him on
screen at least by the Ahsoka series episodes the
zunusine of grogu leaving a larger ship's cargo
bay floating in his new pod with the top off so
that he can see what's going on and then there's
new footage of them flying over the wreckage of
the Dome City the mandalorians on the Mandalore
Planet just to remind you that like this is the
goal during the season then going back to the
actual Planet Mandalore that really is like
the big goal of Mando during season three is
regaining his honor by doing what the armor
told him to do basking in these Waters they
were supposedly buried when the Empire bombed
the planet during the Great Purge I don't know
how much actual time we're going to spend on the
Mandalore planet in present day though because
there's so much footage on other planets and like
I said there's a bunch of other stuff that they've
been teasing like all the grand Admiral thrawn
stuff and the whole plot with Dr Pershing and
cloning grogu trying to create Force sensitive
clones we'll see what that actually connects to
because the funny thing is if you're a big fan of
Star Wars Legends if you read a lot of those heir
to the Empire trilogy books that Timothy Zahn
wrote there was a Luke clone during that there
were clones of Jedi Masters during that and it
seems like the grogu cloning plot connects more
with something towards that like they Apollonia
John Favreau are adapting a lot of the thrawn
trilogy plot points into this newer Mandalorian
storyline we'll see what kind of force sensitive
clones we see in future series because it sounds
like it's going to be a little while before they
completely pay that up but I think because Dr
Pershing seems like a bigger deal during season
three we'll get at least enough Clues to know
where that's headed in a more concrete way if
you haven't read that classic thrawn Trilogy
from back in the 90s it was actually a pretty
fantastic trilogy but some of it isn't Canon yet
like Mara Jade is a big part of that storyline
and she hasn't been brought back into the Canon
yet it's just that a lot of the grand Admiral
thrawn stuff from that story seems like it's
resurfacing now during the Mandalorian season
3 and what's happening with the Ahsoka series
I'll do more videos for the Mandalorian season
3 and the Ahsoka series when we get more teaser
trailer videos later this year they're still going
to be working on that stuff for a while as I'm
making this video they're in the middle of the
Marvel version of the d23 panel there might be a
couple big Marvel trailers whatever they wind up
releasing of course they'll do videos for those
two so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
in my Full House the Dragon episode 4 video will
also Post Sunday just like normal everyone click
here for my Ahsoka trailer breakdown in Easter
eggs and click here for all my Marvel trailer
videos I'll update the link as soon as I post
videos for all those Marvel videos they release!